all right she's an activist
and star of the meddler which debuts
April 22nd Susan Sarandon
serve my could you do that making the
movie no falling down Mountain and
Columbia you know how that go you are
unbelievable time is not laid a glove on
you ah really right am i right and I
don't sleep hardly at all really happy
oh I'm gonna get you know with Ariana on
me I already got me all right I got well
I saw your movie it's so charming I
really needed some softer you yeah I am
a softy sure I heard Trump say the other
day that he never cries I don't cry I
cry at movies that's a cry in life yeah
like any movie um but yeah I you know
this is the kind of movie like if they
made it in 1980 it would be ordinary
people and it would be all over every
theater and I just worry that movies
like this you know there's no cars
punching each other yeah we're we're
entering this era where movies like this
property are only gonna be seen at home
but everyone has a mother
pretty much right and it's about mothers
and kids and yeah and you know I like I
like movies that are about people taking
a chance to connect and cuz connections
everything no it's really well rich
funny it's funny there's a lot of funny
people in it it's got a good ending you
know it is pretty good at JK Simmons
yeah what an actor what no you know the
first the first time I ever saw him was
on this network he was in the show oz he
played Roxy rapist in the prison and for
years I was scared of him I couldn't
even look at him and now look where he
is he's he's kind of a romantic yeah
thing happening yeah and Rose Byrne yes
Adam it's a really good picture thank
you thank you for help you are also the
meddler in politics yeah yeah look at
that I got an extra plug in there yeah
and some of the Liberals got mad at you
because you said if it's not Bernie that
you don't know if you'll even vote for
Hillary you said maybe Trump would be
better because he'd bring on the
revolution so some of the liberals
didn't read the article or see the
interview they just looked at these
misleading headlines that The Daily
Beast and The Hollywood Reporter and the
hill had put up there saying then I
supported Trump but if you read it or
you saw it I did not say that we're not
thinking you support Trump we're just
wondering well yeah but that's what the
headline was so they went off on it and
said how could you say that buhbuh
buhbuh buhbuh ba and i just said just
look at it read it I didn't say that I
didn't say that and it was really
shocking because it shows you how the
political atmosphere has gotten whipped
into a frenzy with just little bits and
pieces taken out of context I was
looking at even the UM what they took
out of the debates last night cuz I
didn't see the debates I was working and
but then when they did like the top hits
of the debates they would have her like
screaming at him and then you didn't say
the answer you know you don't so you're
getting just a very odd little bits and
pieces of things and I thought that was
what was really amazing when I go vote
for Hillary if it's not burnt I'm not
even admitting that she's gonna get the
nomination I'm not going there no
whoa whoa Bernie Sanders but I've been
saying for months on this show look
until it's not
that's who I'm poor you know I he's
putting on the table what I call a New
Deal just what it is you're the new old
New Deal you pay more in taxes but look
at what you get you guys and many other
things yeah that isn't it protect the
environment you don't get elected to
Wall Street you don't take big farm
money don't take all the money for
months but I've also been saying that if
if the airline cannot board your first
choice eat the chicken ah that should be
Hillary slogan eat the chicken uh are
you going to eat the chicken I'm a
vegetarian I say I must see this is just
where we what happened was that I was
saying cuz he said to me there's some
people that aren't gonna vote for
Hillary I heard and I said well you know
there's a lot of independents
environmentalists Green Party working
families that he's activated into the
Democratic Party that never would have
voted for the Democrat and they're very
principled and very passionate and you
can't just expect them to roll over
you're gonna have to give them something
if you want them to vote because they
are not the same on the environment one
wants fracking one doesn't they're not
the same a lot of it you know what
that's so if you want to get me she's
already come up to the $15 minimum wage
that's nice she didn't support that I
mean an environment great example
Hillary has an eighty-two percent voter
rating from the Conservation Society
I don't care the concert horse has five
she that is your choice in this world
she's boring island cracking all over
dreams yes sir she's not perfect but the
perfect is not on the menu
well I'm not gonna say that I I think
Bernie Sanders is gonna get the
nomination don't burst my bubble okay
all right
I'm not those words can't come out of my
mouth at this all right but you know we
were both for Ralph Nader back in 2000
but he was a third-party candidate that
there was a very specific thing this guy
actually for the Oracle that he has
coming up and worked so hard in and is
the party and you see when you go around
the United States he has really spoken
to people the way that Trump has but
except this instead of picking on people
and putting up walls and persecuting
people he's saying everyone comes
together but it's the same discontent
it's the same need for authenticity it's
the same disrespect for the
establishment and that is a very real
thing that's going on now and that's
exciting because he's activated people
who I think will vote in the midterm
elections that's part of his thing he's
saying it doesn't end here no matter
what happens you have to get out there
Rama said that they didn't show up in
2010 he didn't show up in 24 I don't
think he threw I don't if you follow
through oh come on no I don't think he
did I didn't hear anything after he got
in I think he left the grass roots on
the lawn of the White House Wow I do I
thought you know you know persecute he's
put in jail more whistleblowers he's not
had a good record on a lot of things
that people cared about he has done
wonderful things I agree who has done
wonderful yeah that's a key no buffer
you can attack him he won't do this show
you know and